Wesley you played with the black pieces
and smooth draw for you I would say out
of the the opening you equalize
comfortably how do you feel about the
game
didn't really get the enchanted just
want to play I think
um just just play some good solid moves
and if chances come good if not don't
but I think there were only one moment I
think the funny part is that I played A6
and moved here just by accident
yeah we know Knight F6 is probably the
main move right and then Jeffrey told me
after again after Knight F6 is not like
winning four check Queen A4 check okay
so now it like
uh linear has some games with Knight C6
but Magnus won a game here recently
against that one and if C6 Queen takes
C40 transpose to the slab which Jeffrey
played in the first game
they did not want to see this on the
board no I just played A6 by accident I
had no idea if you can play Queen A4 so
the funny part is now I think if white
plays uh E4 and B5 is okay for black
so maybe I fixed it slightly more
accurate move order
um of course the Africa played Knight
after and move to but then somehow it's
very difficult for me to believe you
that you played A6 by accident I'll give
it to you this time
I'll give it to you this time he played
E3 uh Knight to F6 why not B5 now
I'll be fine it's also a line biting
wife slightly better after A4 Bishop B7
B3 B3 okay E6 take Stakes bcbc Bishop C4
and come up the it seems very dovish but
Bishop on B7 is slightly uh vulnerable
after Knight bd2 B2 rupee one attack
Bishop B7 but I made some dirt with
white and black before many years ago
like this but somehow other engines
sound like well and then the other
critical part I guess they're not so
many critical Parts like he played
bitter before against me in the speed
Chess Championship so takes on move 13.
so you guys already played this position
before yeah in fact A4 he played Knight
to F3 okay I think he's played this a
few times yeah how did you respond in uh
in in that game played the bishop Bishop
D6 oh no actually it was a bit game and
I blundered with Rook d8 like I played
Rook date here 1955 queen queen D6 uh
Queen to D6 oh so the game is not here
huh it doesn't seem like it oh I think
he plays Bishop F3 Knight D5 and then he
played Knight takes up seven
such a fun and game and things are
getting a bit wild it still seems like
you're more or less fine but it's pretty
difficult for sure but we played
differential.com yeah yeah so A4 I guess
and Jeffrey weapon well prepared but
okay play very solid at least he was
also spending a lot of time at this
point yeah it was a one-up I mean he's
trying to get some chances but I think
is if I managed to trade drugs then it's
fine like here I missed Rook B2 Rook C1
okay still at the king I said Rook V8
checking E7 and then Bishop C2 but still
hard to imagine how white can win this
yeah
try to keep contact with the opponent F2
and then the bishop cannot move the pawn
cannot jump forward so still very the
thing if I lost this position with black
recently online but the F Pawn is on G3
not on F3 got it got it so I love that
very similar end games I learned some
some important lessons yeah but with the
double F punch it's much easier to make
it through because you have the Avenue
for uh this [ __ ] page four to attack
the pawn on F2 or what is the reason
behind it oh yeah I mean white can't
Advance with King side one so got it
also he's always got the yeah you're
right weakness and F2 but white can't
make progress on making five the double
punch Wesley yesterday a very difficult
game against a very promising uh player
Christopher you how did you handle uh
that defeat
uh well it's my 80th Championship I'm
used to kind of expected the result
because I always lose to teenagers
championships in 2015 I think I lost to
two teenagers to Serbian and I know I've
Conrad Holt was a teenager
2000 uh
eight eighteen or two I was also losing
at some point in 2019 lost the Wonder so
it happens I mean I always lose rate in
the U.S Championship so it's kind of
expected also this year has 13 games so
the more the merrier but what is it
about teenagers that you necessarily
don't like playing against them it's
their style what do you feel gives you
problems yeah there's more pressure you
know they have nothing to lose they just
go all out for a win like I was very
fortunate a bit thin the Rob in the
Olympiad but uh you know they're very
Carefree their focus is just 100 on
chess they have no like girlfriends or
family
or college you know they probably
homeschooled uh and then they have like
two to three years to figure out if they
want to pursue a chess career or go
outside the university like a Wonder
eventually did but it was he's still
very strong but how are those days for
you how do you remember them worry free
were you worried about which career to
choose you got your rent paid they got
everything yeah for you and don't have
to worry about your clothes you have
your parents keeping an eye on you you
have the Stanford Fellowship so there's
where uh
both are good old days you know if
you're a teenager figuring out what to
do with your life uh for for me I guess
that decision has long been decided I've
been a professional chess player for
eight years now uh I remember back in
those days when
I was 18 19 I I was number 80 in the
world and I wasn't sure if I could make
a career playing chess
so I went to Webster University for two
and a half years I was I didn't even
know what to study I finally ended up
citing studying Finance but then I
figured out that uh uh whether I
graduate or not I'm gonna try my luck
playing chess professionally and then
the Samford scholarship helped a lot uh
obviously but but when as you get older
there's certain pressure
uh playing against uh teenagers like
also like free roof here right now it's
very strong also lost him a few weeks
ago
and and I guess Christopher used played
very aggressively yesterday like uh or
speaking about I was winning at some
point yeah he actually came to the
studio and uh he said that he felt
disrespected on every level by hans's
previous interview not mentioning maybe
his name or saying that the game spoke
for itself because it was so beautiful
yeah how do you see that whole
interaction between these uh two young
men well I guess that can be expected of
hands I mean he's disrespected like
pretty much everybody in the Chess World
yeah at this stage calling other players
idiots and stuff and also beating the
great Magnus but uh and how about
Christopher's response
um what did he say exactly he said that
he felt disrespected by hans's interview
and we didn't know how to approach that
or how exactly he felt disrespected or
why he felt disrespected
well I felt disrespected because fans
just won a game I mean it wasn't a
perfect game it was a good game but and
then he called it brilliant and you know
anybody can lose a game uh
I think pretty much
everyone knows that Tans is probably the
most disrespectful teenager in chess
there are many other good players like
gokesh Arjun Prague and they're they're
very polite even fear of just like a
little angel bokeh I mean it doesn't
doesn't really matter that can be
expected
but the thing is like I noticed
Christopher you was also throwing out
new openings here like he never played
second midnight filter before
and uh you know he's just playing for a
win every game just trying to improve
and
I guess if you lose the game and if you
get trashed out then that's the most
difficult feeling that you can feel as a
chess player but I mean it's a it's a
it's not a big deal there always be
other games and uh
yeah I know it's also soccer you won the
US Junior very connected yes yes so he's
definitely seems to be surging through
the rankings right now he's definitely
adding a lot another layer to his game
yeah 13 and yeah it kind of reminds me
of
a young a Wonderland or Leroy Fang so
we'll see how how it goes I'm just very
grateful that Mishra is not here please
more teenagers more uh pressure yeah
yeah fortunately now I've played every
teenager in the
tournaments to go uh
right then this tournament 10 for you
still were in the yes 11 rounds yeah I
think also one of the problems for me
Levon Fabi I think uh the different time
controls every tournament uh also the
online tournaments I think it's very
difficult to
to change your mindset from playing
Blitz rapid to to classical and back
um if you notice pretty much all the top
players in the world that block a bunch
of rating for no reason like I have no
idea why Maxi marshak for example was
elaborating but I think it's because
they don't really know what to focus on
we focus on online or focus on Rapid or
blitz so before this tournament I really
didn't have
much time to prepare because practicing
a lot on on jazz.com and we have the
Fisher random tournament coming up
um well I'm not making excuses but it is
what it is but I'm just saying that
compared to six years ago in 2016 where
everyone was pretty much playing Just
classical chess month after month uh
things have certainly changed absolutely
more opportunities but also a lot of
changes in the Chess World thank you
very much Wesley and we'll see you in
the rest of your games thank you thank
you indeed Wesley good luck to the rest
I'm sorry but I was really